frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
der frieden ist nun selbstverständlich
krieg ist unvorstellbar geworden
zehn jahre ist es her dass der damals
das der damalige präsident des
europäischen rats herman van rompuy
diese sätze gesprochen hat in oslo war
das bei der verleihung des
friedensnobelpreises an die europäische
union
herman van rompoy worte waren damals
natürlich auf die lage im innern der
europäischen union gemünzt und in der
tat krieg zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
der europäischen union ist auch heute
unvorstellbar das ist und bleibt die
größte errungenschaft der europäischen
einigung
doch beim blick auf die ruinen von mario
pohl die hier oder charkiw beim gedanken
an die massen gedanken die massengräber
von butter oder posthum l bei den
bildern zerschossene häuser zertrümmerte
autos und lebloser körper unschuldiger
frauen männer und kinder wird uns
schmerzhaft bewusst
krieg ist eben nicht überall
unvorstellbar geworden auch in europa
nicht
und frieden ist nur dann
selbstverständlich
wenn wir bereit sind ihn zu verteidigen
das ist die lehre die wir aus russlands
brutalen angriff auf die ukraine ziehen
darin liegt die zeitenwende von der ich
ende februar hier in diesem haus
gesprochen haben wie wir kolleginnen und
kollegen unterschiedliche
herausforderungen und krisen hat die
europäische union in den letzten jahren
bewältigt der krieg in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft ist ohne
jeden zweifel die größte
in einem aber endet auch diese krise den
vorangegangenen einmal mehr erleben wir
je größer der druck von außen ist desto
entschlossener und geeinter handelt die
europäische union
weil der von putin entfachte krieg allem
widerspricht wofür diese union steht die
europäische union ist ein
friedensprojekt geboren aus der idee den
krieg und die feindschaft zwischen den
völkern europas ein für alle mal zu
überwinden
und so länder sind offen frei und
demokratisch
anders als putins autokratie
und wir begegnen uns mit respekt und in
dem wissen dass ausgleich und
kompromissbereitschaft keine schwächen
sind sondern es darin unsere stärke
liegt
mit dieser haltung werden wir die
europäische union fortentwickeln und
dabei ihre geschlossenheit war
auch emanuel makro hat das bei seinem
besuch letzte woche bekräftigt ich bin
dem französischen präsidenten daher sehr
dankbar dass ihn seine erste reise nach
der wiederwahl hierher nach berlin
geführt hat darin liegt auch ein
bekenntnis zur deutsch französischen
zusammenarbeit die stets mehr war als
ein bilaterales projekt ihre aufgabe
liegt darin lösung für die zukunft zu
finden die für alle
mitgliedstaaten tragen
das muss immer der antrieb sein des
deutsch-französischen motors die
zeitenwende erfordert dass wir auch in
europa über den tag hinaus denken dabei
werden wir anknüpfen an die vielen guten
vorschläge die die europäischen bürgern
und bürger im rahmen der
zukunftskonferenz entwickelt haben am
europatag heute vor zehn tagen haben sie
die ergebnisse vorgestellt
den bürgerinnen und bürgern geht es um
eine bürgernahe und effizientere union
das wird auch unser fokus
viele der vorschläge sind ganz konkret
die bürgerinnen und bürger wünschen sich
zum beispiel mehr konsequenz beim
klimaschutz fortschritte bei der
europäischen verteidigung ein
gerechteres und inklusives europa mit
mehr sozialen miteinander
vieles davon kann schnell umgesetzt
werden dafür braucht es keine
langjährigen änderung der verträge dazu
reichen gute vorschläge der kommission
das gilt auch für viele ideen um die eu
effizienter zu machen wie die von uns
geforderten mehrheitsentscheidungen im
rat gerade hier sehe ich dass sich in
den letzten wochen und monaten immer
mehr dieser idee anschließen gut so
wenn die sache es erfordert dann können
wir über eine änderung der verträge
reden auch über ein konvent dass es kein
tabu wichtig aber ist dass wir dabei
größtmöglichen konsens erzielt denn wenn
wir eines nicht brauchen in dieser zeit
dann ist das eine kontroverse zeit und
energie raubende nabelschau zu
institutionellen fragen
dass eine auf an den erwartungen vorbei
die die bürgerinnen und bürger an ein
funktionierendes europa haben die
zeitenwende betrifft auch europa und
deshalb ja wir werden die eu weiter
entwickeln und genauso mutig und
entschlossen wie unsere nationale
antwort wird auch unsere europäische
antwort darauf ausfallen
mit diesem ziel werde ich in zehn tagen
zum sondertreffen der staats und
regierungschefs nach brüssel reisen
deutschlands rolle dabei ist für mich
ganz klar als größtes land tragen die
besondere verantwortung für die
einigkeit der europäischen union und
mehr noch selten zuvor war unsere
zusammenarbeit mit den
wirtschaftsstarken demokratien den g7 so
effektiv und so intensiv in diesen tagen
und wochen unter unserem vorsitz deshalb
blicke ich auch voll zuversicht auf
unser gipfeltreffen ende juni in elm und
selten zuvor war das transatlantische
bündnis so eng so lebendig und so
essentiell wie heute präsident biden hat
großen anteil daran und dafür bin ich
sehr dankbar
uns alle eint ein ziel russland darf
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen die ukraine
muss bestehen
darum geht es darum geht es bei allem
was wir tun bei unseren sanktionen gegen
russland bei der aufnahme millionen
geflüchteter in der europäischen union
bei der humanitären
entwicklungspolitischen und
wirtschaftlichen unterstützung der
ukraine
und ja auch bei der lieferung von waffen
einschließlich schwerem gerät
ich weiß das ist nicht unumstritten in
unserem land auch sie erleben in ihren
wahlkreisen sich viele kontroverse
diskussion sie bekommen zuschriften von
bürgern und bürgern die sich sorgen
machen mir geht es nicht anders
manchen geht unsere unterstützung nicht
weit genug andere wiederum geht sie viel
zu weit und nahezu alle bürgerinnen und
bürger ein die sorge um den frieden in
der ukraine aber auch hier bei uns
ich werde daher eines ganz deutlich
sagen
einen brutal angegriffen land bei der
verteidigung zu helfen darin liegt keine
eskalation
sondern ein beitrag dazu den angriff
abzuwehren
und damit schnellstmöglich die gewalt zu
beenden
noch immer glaubt putin dass er einen
diktat frieden herbeibomben kann
doch er irrt sich
so wie er sich schon im blick auf die
entschlossenheit der ukraine ukraine und
die geschlossenheit unserer bündnisse
und allianzen geirrt hat
einen diktat frieden wird es nicht geben
weil die ukraine ukraine ihnen nicht
akzeptieren und wir auch nicht
erst wenn putin das begreift erst wenn
er versteht dass er die verteidigung der
ukraine nicht brechen kann dann wird er
bereit seien ernsthaft über frieden zu
verhandeln
deshalb stärken wir die ukraine den
rücken auch militärisch wir tun das
überlegt abgewogen und international eng
abgestimmt und es bleibt bei dem was ich
den bürgerinnen und bürgern am 8 mai
gesagt habe es wird keine deutschen
alleingänge geben alles was wir tun muss
russland mehr schaden und zu selbst und
unseren partnern die unternehmen nichts
was die nato zur kriegspartei werden
lässt und
wir werden unsere eigene
verteidigungsfähigkeit sichern und
stärken
dafür braucht die bundeswehr das
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
wir sind dazu in guten gesprächen auch
mit ihrer partei die bei herz und das
sondervermögen fest im grundgesetz zu
verankern dafür bin ich dankbar
denn so bringen wir gemeinsam zum
ausdruck regierung und opposition wir
stellen uns unserer staatspolitischen
verantwortung
das sondervermögen garantiert die
freiheit und sicherheit unseres landes
in dieser schwierigen zeit und mehr noch
mit dem sondervermögen senden wir eine
klare botschaft an freunde und
verbündete ja wir meinen es ernst wenn
wir von beistandspflicht und kollektiver
verteidigung reden
das bevölkerungsreichste und
wirtschaftsstärkste nation europas
leistet deutschland dazu seinen
angemessenen beitrag
das erwarten unsere freunde und erlebten
von uns im rahmen der nato ziele und
dazu sind wir bereit liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen denn wir wissen es ist
diese bereitschaft dieses bekenntnis
einer für alle und alle für einen das
unser transatlantisches bündnis trägt
welch großem wert diese gewissheit hat
das zeigt der wunsch schwedens und
finnlands sich der nato anzuschließen
und ich sage ohne jedes zögern liebe
freundinnen und freunde in schweden und
finnland ihr seid uns herzlich
willkommen mit euch an unserer seite
wird die sache
russlands angriff auf die ukraine hat
auch viele andere länder europas dazu
gebracht 9 über ihre sicherheit ans
nachzudenken viele investieren seither
deutlich mehr in ihre verteidigung oft
standen dabei unsere entscheidung partie
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir diese nun
mit dem sondervermögen umsätzen
auf eines werden wir dabei achten unsere
verteidigungssystem und unsere
investitionen müssen auch europäische
enger koordiniert und besser aufeinander
abgestimmt werden wir alle wissen
wir alle wissen seit jahren um die teure
und ineffiziente vielzahl
unterschiedlichster waffensystem in
europa so kann es nicht weitergehen
deshalb wollen wir unsere
technologischen möglichkeiten stärker
gemeinsam nutzen und die europäische
verteidigungsindustrie enger verzahnt
über die notwendigen schritte werden wir
beim sondergipfel ende des monats
beraten es geht um mehr effizienz und
mehr komplementarität
und nicht zuletzt geht es angesichts der
russischen bedrohung auch darum jetzt
einen großen schritt richtung zukunft zu
gehen zu einer gemeinsamen europäischen
verteidigung die eine starke säule
innerhalb der nato bleibt
den blick voraus zu werfen
heißt auch sich in sachen ukraine weiter
zu unterhalten
hoffentlich früher als später wird der
krieg enden und schon jetzt ist klar der
wiederaufbau der zerstörten
infrastruktur die wiederbelebung der
ukrainischen wirtschaft all das wird
milliarden kosten
daher müssen wir als europäische union
jetzt die vorarbeiten für ein
solidaritätsfonds beginn der sich aus
beiträgen der eu und unserer
internationalen partner speist
damit werden wir den ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer helfen die zerstörung zu
beseitigen die der krieg hinterlässt
solidarisch als europäische freunde und
nachbarn
bereits beim treffen der staats- und
regierungschefs in versailles haben wir
klar gesagt die ukraine ist unsere
europäischen familie
das gilt mit dem solidaritätsfonds
werden wir sie auf ihrem europäischen
weg unterstützen und dabei
rechtsstaatlichkeit gute
regierungsführung und die demokratie
stärken
die ukraine hat beantragt mitglied der
europäischen union zu werden die
kommission wird vor dem europäischen rat
voraussichtlich ende juni ihre
einschätzung zu dem antrag abgeben
und zugleich wissen wir alle
immer neue micro hat recht wenn er
darauf hinweist dass der
beitrittsprozess keine sache von ein
paar monaten oder einigen jahren ist und
deshalb wollen wir uns jetzt darauf
konzentrieren die ukraine schnell und
pragmatisch zu unterstützen über den
besten weg dafür werde ich mit meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen beraten
dass es auf dem weg in die eu keine
abkürzung gibt es doch ein gebot der
fairness gegenüber den sechs ländern des
westlichen balkan
seit jahren unternehmen sie intensive
reformen und bereiten sich auf den
beitritt vor
dass wir unsere zusagen gegenüber
einhalten ist nicht nur eine frage
unserer glaubwürdigkeit
heute mehr denn je liegt ihre
integration auch in unserem
strategischen interesse
es geht nicht allein um die sicherheit
dieser region in der externe kräfte um
einfluss ringen nicht zuletzt muss land
es geht um unsere eigene sicherheit die
ohne einen stabilen europäischen
westbalkan nicht zu haben ist
daher muss auch die eu jetzt gegen
liefern gegenüber dem westlichen balkan
und dafür setze ich mich ein indem ich
gespräche führe um fortschritte bei den
verhandlungen zu erreichen und auch
innerhalb der eu die letzten hindernisse
aus dem weg zu hören indem wir den
sogenannten berliner prozess
wiederbeleben der die regionale
zusammenarbeit unter den sechs
westbalkanstaaten stärkt und in dem ich
noch vor dem europäischen rat im juni in
die region reisen mit der klaren
botschaft im gepäck der westliche balkan
gehört in die europäische union
viele kolleginnen und kollegen ein
weiteres thema wird uns bei unserem
gipfel in zehn tagen intensiv
beschäftigen und auch viele bürgerinnen
und bürger treibt es
es geht um die sicherheit und
unabhängigkeit unserer energieversorgung
es geht um bezahlbare energie beides
müssen wir gewährleisten
national und europäisch und
sowohl national als auch europäische
behalten wir eines immer im blick dass
der von russland verschuldete
preisanstieg niemanden überfordert wir
lassen niemanden allein
das gilt ganz besonders für die
bürgerinnen und bürger mit kleinem und
mittlerem einkommen
sie spüren tagtäglich das durch den
krieg nicht nur der sprit an der
zapfsäule teurer geworden ist sondern
auch lebensmittel vom brot bis zum
speise und
auch betriebe die unter den
energiepreisen leiden und denen die
russland geschäft weggebrochen es können
sich auf unsere unterstützung verlassen
dafür stehen die beiden entlastungspaket
die wir schon beschlossen haben und die
in den nächsten wochen wirken die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage die energie
pauschale von 300 euro die zuschüsse für
familien wohngeldempfänger studierende
und sozialleistungsempfänger die
entlastung beim tanken des neuen euro
ticket als anreiz stärker den
öffentlichen nahverkehr zu nutzen all
das kommt den bürgern und bürgern zugute
direkt schnell und zielgerichtet
und für die unterstützung dieser
maßnahmen durch den bundestag sage ich
herzlich danke
auf europäischer ebene geht es vor allem
darum sicherzustellen dass es keine
engpässe bei der energieversorgung in
einzelnen mitgliedstaaten geben das ist
ein gebot europäischer solidarität
teil einer europäischen lösung ist daher
auch der ausbau der transeuropäischen
energienetze
mittel und langfristig bleibt der einzig
vernünftige weg die einzig vernünftige
antwort auf die derzeitigen probleme am
energiemarkt dass wir uns unabhängig
machen von fossiler energie
dabei gemeinsam vorankommen in europa
hat mein gestriges treffen mit meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen aus dänemark
den niederlanden belgien und
kommissionspräsidentin von allein im
dänischen esbjerg gezeigt
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck und
ich haben mit unseren kolleginnen
kollegen vereinbart die gewinnung und
nutzung von windenergie in der nordsee
gemeinsam noch viel stärker
voranzutreiben
die kommissionspräsidentin hat dabei
ihre vorschläge erläutert um europa
unabhängiger von fossilen
energieimporten aus russland zu machen
und den übergang zu klären mal
neutralität voranzubringen das ist eine
wichtige initiative der kommission
wir werden uns die vorschläge jetzt erst
ansehen und darüber beim
außerordentlichen europäischen rat
beraten wir wollen dass davon impulse
ausgehen zur beschleunigung des ausbaus
der erneuerbaren energien für mehr
energieeffizienz und für die
industrielle transformation auf
das kit verfügt die paket der eu spielt
hier eine entscheidende rolle es muss
vollständig verabschiedet werden so
schnell wie möglich unser ziel ist klar
wir wollen und wir werden die
souveränität europas auch in
energiefragen erhöhen und europas
klimaziele erreichen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen nicht nur
an dieser stelle zeigt sich wie
tiefgreifend die folgen des russischen
krieges sind weit über die
sicherheitspolitik hinaus bei der
energieversorgung bei den
rohstoffpreisen
bei der weltweiten versorgung mit
nahrungsmitteln
viele länder in der welt müssen sich
sorgen machen wie das weitergeht
angesichts des kriegs in der ukraine und
in vielen anderen bereichen unseres
lebens
ich habe daher schon zu beginn des
russischen angriffs gesagt die folgen
dieses krieges treffen auch uns und
zugleich bin ich fest davon überzeugt
wir werden die folgen bewältigen hier
bei uns in europa und auch weltweit
weil wir ein starkes land sind mit
starken partnern und allianzen vor allem
aber weil wir wissen was wir verteidigen
frieden freiheit und
recht schönen dunk
gibt es nur wenn wir bereit sind zu
zahlen gingen bei der verteidigung der
ukraine zu helfen sei keine eskalation
russland dürfe diesen täglich gewinnen
so deutliche worte des bundeskanzlers
die vielzitierte zeiten währende
betreffe auf europa das geeinte sei als
je zuvor eine gemeinsame europäische
verteidigung für ihn unabdingbar
ebenso wie eine neue energiepolitik
sowie beifall aus den eigenen reihen für
die regierungserklärung des kanzlers
traditionell folgt nun als nächster
redner der oppositionsführer friedrich
merz wird als nächstes reden erst
fraktionsvorsitzender der union
ich eröffne nun die aussprache und als
ärzte hat das wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion friedrich merz
war
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich werde mich nicht einreihen in eine
gruppe von leuten die für ein kurzes
rein und raus mit einem fototermin was
machen
das war
rund 20 tat zwar ein zitat des
bundeskanzlers aus einem interview auf
die frage wann er denn jetzt nach kiew
reisen wollte herr bundeskanzler wen
meinen sie denn mit dieser gruppe von
leuten
meinen sie damit
bei ihnen liegen aber nach dem letzten
wahlsonntag die nerven wirklich planen
frage sie nochmal der bundeskanzlerin
meinen sie denn mit sieht ja jetzt
immerhin kleine jungs und mädels mehr
die sie daraus ziehen sondern eine
gruppe von leuten also ist dass die
bundestagspräsidentin oder sind es die
drei ausschussvorsitzenden ist dass der
generalsekretär der vereinten nationen
ist dass nancy pelosi die sprecherin des
amerikanischen repräsentantenhauses sind
das die ministerpräsidenten aus polen
tschechien und slowenien oder ist das
etwa die bundes außenministerin die
heute aus guten gründen hier nicht dabei
sein kann sie sprechen immer so viel
auch in ihrer rede heute von respekt ich
möchte an dieser stelle einfach
denjenigen die aus deutschland der
bundes aussenministerin und der
bundestagspräsidentin einmal herzlich
dank sagen und respekt ausdrücken dass
sie diese reise gemacht haben herzlichen
dank dafür
auch aufschlussreich dass da nur die
unionsfraktion jetzt klaut spricht aber
gut meine damen und herren die ukraine
braucht auch weiterhin die solidarität
der internationalen staatengemeinschaft
und das haben sie herr bundeskanzler mit
ihrer regierungserklärung heute richtig
und zutreffend zum ausdruck dass brutale
morden an der bevölkerung der ukraine
und die sinnlose zerstörung dieses
landes durch die russischen aggression
gehen täglich weiter wir begreifen jeden
tag mehr wie furchtbar dieser krieg ist
und wie tief greifend er die politische
ordnung nicht nur in europa sondern auf
der ganzen welt verändern wird vor
diesem hintergrund ist es gut und
richtig dass die staats und
regierungschefs der europäischen union
in der übernächsten woche zu einem
außerordentlichen treffen zusammenkommen
der deutsche bundestag hat ihnen der
bundeskanzler auf dem weg dorthin in der
gemeinsamen entschließung die wir mit
großer mehrheit am 28 april abschied
haben einen klaren beschluss gegeben
eine grundlage gegeben welche schritte
wir aus der mitte des parlaments hier in
deutschland für richtig und für
notwendig halten wir wollen und wir
müssen dem land finanziell und humanitär
weiterhelfen und ich würde an dieser
stelle
ein herzlich dank sagen an alle
humanitären organisationen in
deutschland aber auch an die vielen
familien die geflüchtete frauen mütter
mit ihren kindern aufnehmen in schutz
und zuflucht in deutschland gewähren
dies ist ein großartiges zeichen unseres
landes
sie sollen einvernehmlich hier in diesem
haus mit sanktionen dafür sorgen dass
dieses putin regime getroffen wird dass
der gesamte militärisch industrielle
komplex dieses landes so hart wie
möglich getroffen wird und meine damen
und herren ja auch das ist konsens hier
in diesem haus jedenfalls in der
politischen mitte dieses hauses wir
wollen und wir müssen der ukraine mit
waffen helfen damit dieses land sein
recht zur selbstverteidigung wahrnehmen
kann nun stellen sich allerdings
in diesem zusammenhang herr
bundeskanzler eine ganze reihe von
fragen sie haben hier richtigerweise in
ihrer regierungserklärung betont dass
mit diesen waffen lieferungen an die
ukraine keine eskalation dieses
konfliktes verbunden sind die
einschätzung teilen wir aber warum sagen
sie denn in interviews mehrfach
hintereinander
genau diesen sachverhalt und männern
waffenlieferungen aus europa und aus
deutschland als eine mögliche gefährdung
einer eskalation das passt doch nicht
zusammen was sie heute morgen hier
gesagt haben und dass sie immer wieder
auch im interview zu diesem thema sagen
und
dann erwecken sie den eindruck dass
diese waffenlieferungen stattfinden die
wahrheit ist doch dass aus deutschland
in den letzten wochen so gut wie nichts
an waffen geliefert worden ist wir
wissen es doch wir können doch die
dokumente einsehen es wird praktisch
nichts geliefert stattdessen versprechen
sie den gepard das ist ein waffensystem
dass die ukraine gar nicht haben wollte
das ist das komplizierteste waffensystem
dass es überhaupt gibt und für dieses
waffensystem gibt es keine munition was
machen sie denn was treiben sie denn da
für ein spiel auch mit der deutschen
öffentlichkeit wenn es um diese
waffenlieferungen
sie sprechen sagt wochen sie sprechen
seit wochen von einem so genannten ring
der da von statten gehen soll der hat
bis heute nicht stattgefunden
sie erklären dass unternehmen die noch
waffensysteme auf ihren höfen stehen
haben liefern dürfen seit wochen
beklagen diese unternehmen mit leute
öffentlich dass sie die
exportgenehmigungen der bundesregierung
für diese waffenlieferungen nicht kommen
was ist da eigentlich los welches
doppelte spiel wird da eigentlich in
ihrer regierung betrieben meine damen
und herren ich bin geneigt ich bin
geneigt herrnhofer hier nochmal zu
zitieren der wie ich finde in diesem
zusammenhang gar nicht zu unrecht gesagt
hat das problem sitzt im kanzleramt
meine damen und herren und so scheint es
die der partie sein
sie sprechen dann gleichzeitig der
bundesverteidigungsministerium mit
ministerin ihr vertrauen aus einer
ministerin die seit wochen mehr mit
selbstverteidigung als mit
verteidigungspolitik beschäftigt ist und
am letzten wochenende am letzten
wochenende ist ein bericht in der presse
erschienen meine damen und herren der
nun endgültig belegt dass diese
ministerin das vertrauen der soldatinnen
und soldaten der bundeswehr nicht mehr
erreichen wird deswegen dem ich ihnen
den rat trennen sie sich von dieser
ministerin so schnell wie möglich sie
werden es sowieso irgendwann in den
nächsten wochen und monaten machen
müssen also machen sie ist halt damit es
mit der bundeswehr auch wieder wirklich
voran gehen und vor diesem hintergrund
vor diesem hintergrund werden sie
verstehen dass wir im zusammenhang mit
dem vorschlag eines sondervermögens über
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
besonders sorgfältig umgehen ja wir sind
in gesprächen ob das gute gespräche sind
zahlen war dahin gestellt wir sind uns
jedenfalls bisher nicht einig gut sind
sie nur in einer hinsicht wir die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ist die
einzige fraktion in diesem bundestag die
ihnen mit dem was sie gesagt haben in
ihrer regierungserklärung am 27 februar
nämlich 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr und dauerhaft mehr als zwei
prozent unseres bip in jedem jahr für
die verteidigung wir sind die einzige
fraktion die ihn in diesem weg
uneingeschränkt folgen will den
widerspruch ist nicht von uns den gibt
es auf ihren regierungsfraktionen
bundeskanzler
sie haben sie haben angesprochen in
ihrer regierungserklärung das
beschaffungs system wir sind uns mit
ihnen einig dass wir daran etwas
wirklich grundlegendes ändern müssen wir
können diese 100 milliarden nicht noch
einmal so
wir sind uns einig mit ihnen was ist
denn daran auf den zur aufregung wir
sind mit ihnen einig dass wir dieses
beschaffungs system ändern wollen ich
möchte nur heute fast drei monate
nachdem sie den vorschlag gemacht haben
einmal feststellen es gibt dazu aus
ihrer koalition bis heute keinen
einzigen vorschlag wie das denn gehen
soll also die beschwörung einer
notwendigkeit was da alles geändert
werden muss ist das eine aber praktische
politik in der richtigen kompetenzen des
bundeskanzlers sehen wir zu diesem
zeitpunkt nicht meine damen und herren
und dann lassen wir ihn abschließend
lassen sie mich abschließend einige
themen ansprechen die sie nur am rande
oder gar nicht angesprochen haben ja wir
sind der meinung dass der westbalkan in
die europäische union aufgenommen werden
sollte wir sind mit ihnen der meinung
dass die ukraine eine
beitrittsperspektive haben muss in die
europäische union aber was sagt denn die
bundesregierung der bundesrepublik
deutschland auf diese frage sind sie für
einen kandidatenstatus der ukraine oder
sind sie es nicht es wäre doch eine gute
gelegenheit gewesen dass heute morgen
mal in deutschland zu sagen
wie stehen sie
wie stehen sie zu dem wunsch der ukraine
nach diesem krieg den wir hoffentlich
bald zu ende gehen sehen
sicherheitsgarantien auch aus
deutschland zu bekommen sind sie bereit
solche sicherheits garantien zu geben ja
oder nein wie soll der wiederaufbau der
ukraine denn finanziert werden sie sagen
einen solidaritätsfonds damit können wir
uns durchaus anfreunden mit diesem
gedanken aber wie soll dieser
solidaritätsfonds denn finanziert werden
sind sie mit teilen der eu kommission
der auffassung dass dies mit
zusätzlichen neuen schulden der
europäischen union gemacht werden soll
oder sind sie dagegen sagen sie doch uns
ihre meinung zu diesen zentralen themen
um die es dann auch geht in der welt von
morgen nach diesem krieg und dann zwei
letzte anderen
der französische staatspräsident hat bei
seinem besuch hier in berlin ja
vorgeschlagen ein neues system der
integration der heranführung
verschiedener staaten an die europäische
union zu entwickeln er hat davon
gesprochen die demokratien der welt um
die europäische union herum zu einen wie
soll das denn gehen wir sind dafür dass
das stattfindet aber wie soll es den
institutionell gingen sind sie der
meinung dass zum beispiel der
europäische wirtschaftsraum gestärkt
werden soll dass die öfter
möglicherweise ein instrument sein
könnte sind sie der auffassung das
assoziierungsabkommen mit der
europäischen union auf den weg gebracht
werden sollten um diese heranführung an
die europäische union zu ermöglichen und
dann haben sie über eine zuständigkeit
der europäischen union überhaupt nicht
gesprochen die sie nämlich neben der
währungspolitik fast ganz alleine hat
aber auf die zustimmung der
mitgliedstaaten angewiesen muss die an
kein wort über die handelspolitik
verloren meine damen und herren ja wir
brauchen energie wir brauchen gas wir
brauchen kohle wir brauchen öl aus
vielen anderen ländern der welt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister ist in katar
unterwegs um gaslieferungen nach
deutschland zu ermöglichen aber warum um
gottes willen lehnen sie bis in diese
woche hinein die befassung des deutschen
bundestages mit dem fertig gestellten
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada immer wie
ab gestern
investors und wirtschaft weil dass sich
die mehrheit ihrer koalition
dieses abkommen auf die tagesordnung des
deutschen bundestages zu setzen es
weigert sich die mehrheit ihrer
koalition auch einmal über die frage zu
sprechen wie wir denn die
handelsbeziehungen zu den vereinigten
staaten von amerika weiter entwickeln
soll mit katar gaslieferungen zu machen
und mit kanada kein abkommen
abzuschließen über den freihandel herr
bundeskanzler ihre politik wird nicht
glaubwürdiger dadurch dass sie es auf
diese art und weise zu lassen und
schließlich zum schloss sie verlieren
kein wort sie verlieren kein wort über
den umgang der europäischen union mit
den zwei größten ländern dieser welt
nämlich mit indien und mit china zwei
länder die sich im verein in der verein
in der vollversammlung der vereinten
nationen ihrer stimme enthalten haben
als es um die verurteilung der
aggression in russland wie soll diese
europäische union ihre beziehungen zu
indien und china den entwickeln
angesichts dieser weigerung sich auf die
seite der freiheitlichen und
demokratischen staaten der welt zu
stellen darauf muss europa doch eine
antwort geben und europa kann nur eine
antwort geben dann ist dazu eine
vorstellung der bundesregierung der
bundesrepublik deutschland gibt ohne sie
wird es nicht gehen der bundeskader sie
müssen dazu etwas sagen
und deswegen lassen sie nicht lassen die
nicht zu der schlussfolgerung gekommen
denn wenn zeitenwende wirklich der
epochenwandel ist den sie in ihrer
regierungserklärung am 27 februar hier
von dieser stelle aus beschrieben haben
dann bleibt jedenfalls die heutige
regierungserklärung von ihnen weit
hinter den notwendigkeiten zurück um
eine solche epochenwende wirklich aktiv
zu gestalten
da muss mehr kommen will ist unklar das
denn jetzt das
war die rede des oppositionsführers
mitzieht am bundestag friedrich merz ist
kein zweifel daran dass deutschland der
ukraine auch mit waffenlieferungen
helfen müsse kritisierte aber dass zu
wenig geliefert werde aus deutschland
zum thema sondervermögen sei man im
gespräch aber mehr auch noch nicht
erneut forderte merz dass die 100
milliarden ausschließlich für die
bundeswehr verwendet werden und zudem
kritisierte er dass scholz keine antwort
gegeben habe auf solche themen wie
solidaritätsfonds für die ukraine eu
beitritts option ukraine oder den umgang
mit indien und china
es folgt nun als nächste rednerin
katharina dröge die co
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90
grüne
[Musik]
die nächste rednerin für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen katharina dröge
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr merz ich frage mich warum
ihre reden in diesen generaldebatte
eigentlich immer beginnen wir zertreten
ich finde dass es der debatte einfach
nicht angemessen
wir sind hier sehr deutsche bundestag
wir tragen die verantwortung für dieses
land mitten in europa in einer zeit in
der der frieden in europa so sehr
herausgefordert wird wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht mehr es ist
unangemessen so zu beginnen ist es
angemessen damit zu beginnen was hier
wirklich vor uns liegt wir sind in einer
zeit in der iss die europäische union so
dringend braucht wie nie zuvor wir sind
in einer zeit in der es europäische
einigkeit geschlossenheit und
entschlossenheit so dringend braucht wie
nie zuvor angesichts der aggression von
putin angesichts eines krieges gegen die
ukraine der mit aller brutalität geführt
wird ist es so wichtig und richtig dass
die mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union hier gemeinsam und geschlossen
stehen
und ja
es sind keine einfachen entscheidung die
wir in diesen tagen treffen müssen und
ich verstehe jeden der angesicht dieser
entscheidung mit sich ringt aber
wenn man sich ernsthaft mit dem
auseinandersetzt was da in der ukraine
gerade passiert dann kann nicht handeln
keine option sein wer nicht handeln
heißt weiter zuzulassen was in butter
was in mario pohl und was in vielen
anderen orten in der ukraine täglich
passiert nicht zu handeln heißt einen
krieg zu lassen der keine grenzen kennt
ein krieg zuzulassen in dem folter und
vergewaltigung mittel des krieges gegen
die menschen in der ukraine sind ein
krieg zuzulassen in dem nachdem der
rückzug der russischen truppen sichtbar
wird die straßen von leichen übersät
sind diesen krieg zulassen es sind
weiter die verschleppung von gefangenen
von kriegsgefangenen nach russlands
zuzulassen mit einem ungewissen
schicksal
diesen krieg zuzulassen hieß das weiter
kinder von ihren eltern getrennt werden
und diesen krieg zulassen es auch
weiterhin einen präsidenten machen zu
lassen der selbst den globalen hunger
selbst die versorgung der ärmsten länder
dieser welt mit nahrungsmitteln so ein
mittels eines krieges gegen den rest der
welt gemacht hat und das ist wichtig und
richtig dass wir dem gemeinsam ein
stoppzeichen entgegensetzen
es ist unsere aufgabe das zu tun und es
war so wichtig dass die deutsche
außenministerin in der vergangenen woche
in kiel für die ganze bundesregierung
noch einmal deutlich gemacht hat wir
arbeiten jeden tag an weitere maßnahmen
an noch mehr unterstützung für die
ukraine unsere botschaft an putin ist
wir werden niemals aufhören die ukraine
zu unterstützen unsere unterstützung
gilt solange sie notwendig ist
und wir haben das heißt lieferung
fortschritt in sachen denn die ukraine
muss sich verteidigen können und das
heißt weitere wirtschaftliche sanktions
pakete zu beschließen 5 hat die
europäische union schon geschafft fünf
mit denen wir schnell entschlossen und
konsequent russland so weit es geht aus
dem globalen handel isoliert haben jetzt
steht ein sechstes sanktionspaket an
eines mit dem wir weitere russische
banken vom finanzsystem abkoppeln werden
und es steht auch an dass sich die
europäische union auf einem weg für ein
öl embargo einigt der die abkopplung von
fossilen importen aus russland ist das
stärkste instrument was wir
wirtschaftlich russland entgegensetzen
können
und ja es ist auch eine zeit in der die
europäische union gezeigt hat was sie
kann sie hat gezeigt dass die grenzen
öffnen kann sie hat gezeigt dass es
möglich ist in so einer krise die
menschen aus der ukraine
hierauf zu nehmen ihnen schutz zu bieten
einfach unbürokratisch schnell
unkompliziert und ich finde das muss der
maßstab sein auch dann wenn andere
menschen aus anderen regionen der welt
vor krieg terror und folter zu uns
fliegen dann muss die europäische union
diesen maßstab auch zum maßstab ihres
handelns machen
und ja wir müssen die ukraine
unterstützen auf ihrem weg in die
europäische union und ich bin sehr froh
dass der deutsche bundestag in der
letzten sitzungswoche dieses signal so
gemeinsam und entschlossen ausgesendet
hat denn die europäische union steht
gerade jetzt für das gegenteil von dem
wofür russland steht die europäische
union ist ein projekt des friedens eine
gemeinschaft des rechts und eine
gemeinschaft gemeinsamer werte für uns
sind meinungsfreiheit demokratie und
menschenrechte das fundament auf dem wir
die europäische union aufgebaut haben
und das müssen wir jetzt umso dringender
verteidigen
und angesichts der russischen aggression
stehen wir auch in sicherheitsfragen
geschlossener zusammen denn je und
deshalb freue ich mich über die
entscheidung von finnland und schweden
jetzt der nato jetzt ein gemeinsam
sicherheitsbündnis beizutreten wir
werden hier im deutschen bundestag diese
schnell es geht handeln um diesen
weitere zu ermöglichen und wir werden
auch als ampel fraktion jetzt in dieser
zeit mehr in unsere gemeinsame
sicherheit zu investieren
aber herr merz es geht um gemeinsame
sicherheit und deswegen finde ich es
völlig unverständlich dass sie
ausgerechnet in dieser zeit als unions
fraktion aus einer grundgesetzänderung
die dem deutschen bundestag vorliegt das
bekenntnis zur stärkung der bündner das
fähigkeit streichen wollen was ist das
für ein signal an die nato-partner
drinnen saß ein signal an die länder die
gerade mit diesem namen werden sollten
dass das braucht in der nato unseres
kollektiven sicherheiten grundes haben
dass ich das aus dieser durch die
wertänderung streichen wollen sicherheit
im 21 jahrhundert denkt man nicht mehr
national sondern gemeinsam
und
gleichzeitig das schicksal dieser
generation die heute politische
verantwortung trägt das mit zwei krisen
gleichzeitig lösen müssen auf der einen
seite müssen wir die frage der
sicherheit in europa beantworten und auf
der anderen seite nimmt die klimakrise
mit unbarmherziger geschwindigkeit zu
der blick nach indien und pakistan
menschen seit über zwei monaten unter
beispielloser held zu leiden zeigt wie
real die klimakrise jetzt schon ist wie
sehr der planet schon jetzt unter dem
leidet was wir durch unser handeln in
den letzten jahrzehnten verursacht haben
und deswegen ist es jetzt dringend zeit
alles dafür zu tun hier umzusteuern und
passen unsere antworten sogar zusammen
denn die frage der energie souveränität
von europa ist gleichzeitig auch eine
frage der souveränität und
unabhängigkeit von fossilen und diese
frage müssen auch sie als union
beantworten zu diesem thema habe ich von
ihnen in ihrer rede nichts gehört herr
merz jetzt ist die zeit um ins zu
investieren gemeinsam in der
europäischen union in den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien jetzt ist die zeit
zu investieren in eine
wasserstoffwirtschaft die ärmsten acht
damit dass die wirtschaft auch umstellen
kann auf eine klimaneutrale produktion
jetzt ist die zeit zu investieren in
einen ausstieg aus fossilen gas das
thema energieeffizienz ist ein zentrales
klima thema aber es ist auch ein
zentrales wirtschaftsthema und das
müssen wir gemeinsam europäisch
beantworten
und ja wir ernst meint mit der
unabhängigkeit von russland er muss auch
mit der deutschen wirtschaft ernsthaft
sprechen denn der glaube dass wir
irgendwann in den nächsten zwei oder
drei jahren wieder anfangen können damit
gas oder kohle oder öl aus russland zu
kaufen den muss ich ihnen nehmen es ist
die klare ansage stellen sie sich darauf
ein wir werden nie wieder so abhängig
von fossilen aus russland werden nie
wieder so abhängig von gas aus russland
und darauf müssen sie sich vorbereiten
das heißt was gegen die kadetten ich
weiß dass das wird nicht eintreffen
können über politische unterstützung
reden aber glauben sie nicht daran dass
wir auf diesem weg noch einmal umkehren
werden das schulden wir der sicherheit
in europa das schulden wir auch der
zukunft unserer kinder mit blick auf die
unabhängigkeit von fossilen und das ist
die gemeinsame antwort die sie und wir
zusammen geben müssen
katharina dürr die fraktionsvorsitzende
von bündnis 90/grüne verteidigt
waffenlieferungen an ukraine man müsse
putin ein stoppzeichen entgegen setzen
auf die zahlreichen sanktionen seien
richtig es war eine rede die vor einem
jahr hier von einer vertreterin der
grünen friedenspartei keiner erwartet
hätte gleichzeitig fordert rüge ein
umsteuern in der energiepolitik die
klimakrise sei die zweite krise derzeit
es folgt nun alice weide von der afd
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler sehr geehrte
damen und herren
deutschland steckt politisch
wirtschaftlich und finanziell in einer
der schwersten krise seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg
die inflation ist dauerhaft auf hohem
niveau angekommen und stranguliert
mittelstand und mittelschicht das wurde
heute mit keinem wort erwähnt unsere
energieversorgung steht auf der kippe im
herbst droht ein
zusammenbruch
die migrations krise ist ungelöst der
ansturm illegaler migration über das
mittelmeer und über die land routen
erreichen neuer höchststände der
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine ist ein katalysator der die
krise zugespitzt hat und die defizite
unserer militär und sicherheitspolitik
offen liegt und dass ihre koalition
sich nicht einmal darauf einigen kann
für die bundeswehr
vorgesehenen 100 milliarden tatsächlich
in unsere eigene armee zu stecken zeigt
dass die botschaft noch immer nicht bei
ihnen angekommen ist und die ursache der
krise ist aber eine ganz andere und zwar
eine falsche vier geleitete politik die
energiewende hat mit dem gleichzeitigen
ausstieg aus der atomkraft und kohle
nutzung die energie preise hochgetrieben
und die einseitige abhängigkeit von
russischem erdgas erst verursacht sie
saßen in der regierung kanzler chance
verantwortungslose schuldenpolitik
verboten der monetäre staatsfinanzierung
und die null zinspolitik der ezb
infolge dessen die abwertung des euros
und dadurch erhöhte importpreise sind
doch die eigentliche ursache der
inflation auch das wurde heute nicht
erwähnt die repression über corona
politik und undurchdachte sanktionen
haben lieferketten zerbrochen und das
angebot verknappt während die geldmenge
explodiert der verfall des euros auf den
bürgern kaufkraft und wohlstand härtere
klimaziele und der forcierte ausbau
sogenannter
erneuerbarer energien werden uns nicht
unabhängiger machen sondern die energie
krise sogar noch verschärfen
härtere klimaziele
werden unseren haushalt plündern sie
werden uns ein haushalt so belasten wie
wir es noch nicht gesehen haben und sie
werden nicht weitermachen können mit den
schulden den schulden staatliche
schulden heizen inflation immer mehr an
und verdrängen die private nachfrage die
russland sanktionspaket sind
kontraproduktiv sie schaden deutschland
und europa mehr als russland
öl und gas embargo gegen russland wäre
vollends ruinös denn ein tragfähiger
ersatz für die ausfallenden lieferung
steht in den sternen
hochgefährlich sind pläne das
einstimmigkeitsprinzip in zentralen
fragen abzuschaffen das ist eine
antidemokratische entmündigung der
nationalstaaten
gemeinsame schulden für den wiederaufbau
der ukraine sind nichts anderes als ein
weiterer ausbau der schuldenunion zu
lasten der deutschen steuerzahler
und unter dem deckmantel des kampfes
gegen desinformation und missbrauch
betreibt die eu die totalüberwachung der
privaten kommunikation
und darüber hinaus plant man auch noch
ein eu-weites vermögens register um alle
privaten besitztümer zu erfassen das ist
ein weiterer schritt zur enteignung der
bürger um ihnen die flucht aus dem
verfallenden inflations geld in
sachwerte zu verbauen herr bundeskanzler
wenn sie zum eu ratstreffen fahren dann
lautet ihre vornehmste pflicht deutsche
interessen zu wahren und diesen
bestrebungen entgegen zu treten räumen
sie der bekämpfung der inflation und der
sicherung der energieversorgung
oberste priorität ein die inflation
beraubt die bürger sie ist die
unsozialste aller steuern sie ist eine
kalte vermögenssteuer die vor allem die
arbeitende produktive mit der wirtschaft
und gesellschaft trifft inflation
bekämpft man nicht mit umverteilung
sondern mit weniger schulden
steuersenkung und konzentration auf
strategische kernaufgaben des staates
verlassen sie also den ihr weg der
energiewende sorgen sie dafür dass kohle
und kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen und
abgeschaltete reaktoren wieder
hochgefahren werden denn laut eu ist
atomkraft grün und co2 neutral und vor
allem tun sie alles um den krieg in
europa schnell zu beenden wir teilen
ihre sorge einer eskalation sie haben
festgestellt dass russland nicht
gewinnen darf aber als atommacht auch
nicht in eine ausweglose lage gedrängt
werden sollte der kriege in der ukraine
ist nicht unser krieg wir dürfen uns von
parolen propaganda und emotionen nicht
fort reißen lassen sondern müssen unsere
eigenen interessen vertreten und die
sind waffenstillstand und frieden der
ukraine ich hab ein stadium erreicht in
dem statt ständig neuer
waffenlieferungen der verhandlungsweg
beschritten werden muss um einen
jahrelangen abnutzungskrieg zu
verhindern und stellen sie sich den
extremen grünen gefühls politikern
hingegen die vom infantilen pazifismus
umstandslos auf moralisierende polizist
muss umgeschaltet haben und erinnern sie
ihre minister daran dass inhaltsleere
fragen noch keine außenpolitik sind wer
nach kia fährt muss auch nach moskau
fahren um gesprächsfaden wieder
aufzunehmen
beschreiten sie bitte den weg der
vernunft vielen herzlichen dank
von alois weigl wie zu erwarten heftige
kritik an der regierung diese sei
verantwortlich für die inflation für
ungeregelte migration für die
energiekrise und mache eine falsche
schuldenpolitik der kanzler müsse zuerst
die inflation bekämpfen und steuern
senken weniger schulden machen zu alice
weiter es folgt nun christian doerr der
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen
84 tage krieg in der ukraine
man befürchte 10.000 tote zivilistinnen
und zivilisten
mindestens 10.000 tote ukrainische
soldaten und über 15.000 verwunderte 13
millionen geflüchtete oder vertriebene
im eigenen land über 30 prozent der
infrastruktur der ukraine sind zerstört
die lage in der ukraine ist eine
tragödie der angriffskrieg russlands
leid meine damen und herren für immer
unentschuldbar und ich sage 1 an dieser
stelle wir dürfen uns an die bilder aus
der ukraine nicht gewöhnen wir
das sage ich insbesondere vor dem
hintergrund der rede meiner vorrednerin
wir in deutschland die europäische union
der gesamte westen wir müssen alles tun
was wir können um diesen krieg zu
beenden und die integrität der ukraine
wieder herzustellen meine damen und
herren das ist kein humanitäre
verpflichtungen jedem kollegen und
kollegen
und das ist jetzt gerade unsere aufgabe
die europäischen werte der freiheit der
selbstbestimmung und der
wirtschaftlichen eigenständigkeit
aufzuzeigen wir teilen diese werte mit
den ukrainerinnen und ukrainer und
deshalb ist es das richtige zeichen
meine damen und herren der ukraine jetzt
den europäischen weg aufzuzeigen auch
das will ich deutlich sagen
die konsequenzen dieses krieges für die
internationale ordnung sind dramatisch
denn das alte kommt nicht wieder die
alte welt auch die alpen beziehung zu
russland werden so nicht wiederkommen es
geschieht übrigens nun das was russland
immer verhindern wollte wir stehen als
westliche verbündete zusammen dass
schweden und finnland jetzt den beitritt
zur nato beantragt haben meine damen und
herren ist ein richtiges und gutes
zeichen wir heißen findet und schweden
in der nato sehr herzlich willkommen auf
das muss deutlich gesagt werden
und was uns als europäer europäer was
uns als europäische union jetzt auch in
dieser phase so wichtig ist dass wir die
richtigen zeichen setzen dass bereits
vorgesehene öl-embargo müssen wir jetzt
gemeinsam durchsetzen sowohl der
entsprechende beschluss der g7 staaten
als auch die bemühungen der eu aus
russischen öl auszusteigen ist das
richtige zeichen der beschluss des
europäischen ausstiegs und die
unabhängigkeit von russischen
rohstoffimporten ist ein meilenstein
es geht jetzt alles dafür zu tun diesen
beschluss umzusetzen so schnell es geht
es kommt uns als europäerin europäern
jetzt eine ganz entscheidende rolle zu
auch in der welt nicht nur innerhalb der
europäischen union wir müssen darüber
hinaus sehen denn die auswirkung des
krieges gehen weit über europa hinaus es
ist daher die globale verantwortung der
eu insbesondere jetzt auch das thema
nahrungsmittelknappheit in der welt zu
adressieren in europa beobachten wir
eine starke inflation anderswo bedeutet
dieser krieg eine existenzielle
ernährungskrise 47 millionen menschen
sind zusätzlich vom hunger bedroht auch
der hunger in der welt meine damen und
herren auch das will ich sagen der
hunger in der welt ist eine waffe
russlands in diesem krieg wir müssen
verstehen dass was hier als inflation
daherkommt ganz konkret woanders hunger
bedeutet meine damen und herren wir
sollten gerade als europäische union und
deutschland unseren beitrag dazu leisten
wir haben in europa in deutschland eine
sehr starke landwirtschaft auch die
brauchen wir jetzt an dieser stelle es
geht um die ernährungssicherheit in
diesem sommer in der gesamten welt liebe
kollegen voll
und während das zweite die zukunft
ansprechen ist wird jetzt auch bei den
verabredungen innerhalb europas um die
frage des wiederaufbaus der ukraine
gehen die direkte finanzielle und
militärische unterstützung steht jetzt
selbstverständlich im vordergrund aber
die lieferung von waffen die jetzt
wichtig ist das hat ja ein ziel meine
damen und herren jetzt schwere waffen zu
liefern wofür ich der bundesregierung
sehr dankbar bin dass diese entscheidung
aus der mitte des hauses eben auch in
der bundesregierung getroffen worden ist
das hat ein ziel ich will das in aller
klarheit sagen ich war froh über die
integrität der ukraine aber wir müssen
auch jetzt darüber hinaus blicken
nämlich den aufbau der ukraine insgesamt
meine damen und herren wenn wir davon
reden dass die europäische zeit in der
ukraine verteidigt wird dann müssen wir
auch sagen wofür nämlich dass menschen
dort in zukunft in wohlstand leben
können das ist das ziel der menschen in
der ukraine
wir wollen dass die ukraine wieder frei
ist was wir uns immer bewusst machen
müssen die menschen in der ukraine
kämpfen für einen danach in freiheit und
wohlstand meine damen und herren dabei
unterstützen wir sind
und dabei kommt uns jetzt natürlich
unsere wirtschaftliche stärke als westen
und deutschland zugute diese
wirtschaftliche stärke ist zurzeit auch
unsere geopolitische stärke meine damen
und herren und herr kollege merz ich
will dass zum schluss meiner rede sagen
all das was sie hier gesagt haben war
weniger eine abrechnung mit der
bundesregierung es war eine abrechnung
mit ihrer eigenen
regierungsverantwortung als cdu und csu
das war es unser hat das war's in
wahrheit wissen sie herr merz ich hätte
mir
etwas anderes gewünscht man selbst 16
jahre verantwortung für die bundeslehrer
für die soldatinnen und soldaten in
deutschland getragen hat ich hätte nie
etwas anderes gewünscht meine damen und
herren etwas anderes gewünscht wenn man
selbst das 2 prozent ziehen in
regierungsverantwortung fast nie er weg
und in jedem fall haushalterischen die
hochgehalten hat liebe kollegen kollegen
und ich hätte mir
ich hätte mir ich hätte mir etwas
anderes gewünscht auch vor dem
hintergrund dass sie in wahrheit jetzt
ja zum glück mit dem beitritt zu unserem
antrag zum thema waffenlieferung
beitrittsperspektive und so weiter in
der vorvergangenen woche einen anderen
kurs eingeschlagen haben und jetzt
glücklicherweise entschieden haben als
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion bei einer
verfassungsänderung ein abzählreim mehr
aufzuführen herr kollege merz ich will
eins sagen
ich will ich will eines zum schluss
sagen wir haben hier tatsächlich eine
zeitenwende eingeleitet als
ampelkoalition wir liefern waffen in
kriegsgebiete wir brechen die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit einem
ehemaligen handelspartner ab wie
investieren massiv in unserer armee das
hat es vorher nicht gegeben periklis hat
mal gesagt der schlüssel zum glück bis
die freiheit der schlüssel zur freiheit
ist der mut sein wir gemeinsam mutig ich
danke ihnen
das war christian dürr von der fdp
erwarte dafür der ukraine den
europäischen weg zu ebnen gegen müsse
jetzt die richtigen weichen stellen das
öl-embargo der eu sei richtig die eu
habe aber zudem eine globale
verantwortung auch beim thema
nahrungssicherheit in der welt es folgt
admira mohammed badie die
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen auch heute auch
in diesen minuten und sterben in der
ukraine menschen der völkerrechtswidrige
angriff russlands dieser krieg bringt
jeden tag unvorstellbares leid so viele
menschen sind schon gestorben tausende
stehen vor den scherben ihrer existenz
tausende sind auf der flucht ihnen
gehört unsere unumstößliche solidarität
und dann
danken vor allem denjenigen die jetzt
große hilfsbereitschaft zeigen die sich
selbstlos einsätzen für diese menschen
in not es so wichtig klar ist dieser
krieg muss so schnell wie möglich
beendet werden und klar ist auch putin
darf ihn nicht gewinnen
aber wer ernsthaft glaubt dass man
russland die größte atommacht der welt
mit militärischen mitteln in die knie
zwingen kann der irrt einfach im
gegenteil das ist ein hochgefährlicher
kurs
oft wird in der aktuellen debatte aber
leider so getan als gäbe es nur die
alternative zwischen militärischen musik
und kapitulation der ukraine wie
erlebens sogar immer wieder dass
diejenigen die über sofort wieder
diplomatische bemühungen auch nur
sprechen dass die in die nähe putins
gerückt werden besonders wenn das
politisch passt aber das ist doch
quatsch diese harte auseinandersetzung
die hilft doch nicht weiter und sie
hilft vor allem nicht die leidtragenden
ukraine dass die wahrheit
diese technik
mario draghi der hat doch recht wenn er
auf friedensverhandlungen drängt und ja
ich weiss friedensverhandlungen die
brauchen die bereitschaft einen
kompromiss zu finden und dann kompromiss
zu finden wo russland doch die ukraine
überfallen hat das widerspricht dem
gerechtigkeitsempfinden auch meinem
eigenen natürlich aber es kann doch
trifft den britischen premier brown
chancen nicht zustimmen wenn er sagt mit
putin gäbe es nichts zu verhandeln denn
was ist denn die alternative so
diplomatischen lösungen es ist ein immer
länger dauert der krieg mit immer mehr
toten es ist die wachsende gefahr einer
ausweitung des krieges die gefahr eines
dritten weltkrieges und das darf doch
nicht sein kolleginnen kollegen
es heißt oft die türen für die branche
lösungen die wären aktuell verschlossen
aber frau werbung da möchte ich dir mal
fragen wie viele klinken haben sie den
bisher eigentlich ernsthaft probiert
warum wahnsinnig in peking oder neu
geben ich habe manchmal den eindruck
verwechseln das wirklich saison ressort
sie zuständig sind sie sind nicht die
verteidigungsminister sie sind die
außenministerin die chefdiplomatin und
da erwarte ich auch diplomaten von ihnen
deutschland muss gemeinsam mit regen
endlich zu stimme der vernunft wärme und
das kann die eu erinnern wir uns an dem
fünf tage krieg um südossetien zwischen
georgien und russland im jahr 2008 nach
ist eine extrem schwierige situation die
vereinten nationen waren mit ihren
bemühungen bereits gescheitert es war
die eu die ein kompromiss vermittelt bei
dem treffen das europäischen rates
sollte es daher vor allem um gemeinsame
diplomatische anstrengungen gehen
vergessen wird es aber vor allem um
sanktionen gehen aber nicht im
schwerpunkt um sanktionen gegen die
russische führung gegen die mächtige
oligarchen das wäre richtig und auch
wichtig sondern auch allgemeine
sanktionen die in russland vor allem die
bevölkerung treffen und die schon jetzt
in deutschland und der eu einen enormen
wirtschaftlichen schaden anrichten eben
weil diese sanktionen und vor allem die
eigene wirtschaft und damit die eigene
bevölkerung so hart treffen machen viele
länder dabei auch nicht mit und sie
kritisieren die sanktionspolitik der eu
schauen wir nach südamerika dass
südafrika nach indien ich kann verstehen
dass viele menschen angst bekommen in
deutschland wenn sie von geplant und öl
embargo hören weil sie fürchten dass die
lebenshaltungskosten dann noch weiter
steigen oder ist doch jetzt schon so
dass so manche friseurin sich am ende
des monats kein frisches obst mehr für
ihre kinder leisten kann herr scholz sie
behaupten immer das wäre nicht so
signorini deren not diese note ist ist
aber die realität es müssen sie mal zur
kenntnis und
ich kann verstehen dass viele menschen
angst um ihre arbeitsplätze haben den
sie mal nach schwedt die raffinerie dort
die ist auch das rohöl aus russland
angewiesen da kann man sich jetzt
bezahlt er politiker nicht einfach
hinstellen und sagen wir das nun mal der
preis der freiheit das doch wirklich
zynisch sie haben verantwortung für die
menschen in unserem land besonders für
die die jetzt schon kaum wissentlich
über die runden kommen sollen fakt ist
doch ihre entlastungspläne sie heute
wieder angepriesen haben die decken
nicht mal im ansatz die realen
mehrkosten ab und das ist auf uns
zukommen wird euch ein öl embargo ist
darum ein vielfaches gravierender da
helfen keine lippenbekenntnisse und
keine durchhalteparolen es braucht
konsequente maßnahmen zum beispiel die
senkung von verbrauch steuern auf ohne
nahrungsmittel eine funktionierende
staatliche preisaufsicht für die energie
wesentlich höhere direktzahlungen es
braucht einen schutzschirm wir betroffen
unternehmen besonders im osten damit
nicht zum zweiten mal nach der wende
beim auszug reihenweise existenzen
zerstört werden dafür wäre es dringend
notwendig geld in die hand zu nehmen und
zwar wirklich viel geld und nicht in das
sinnlose sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr was nur ein effekt haben wird
nämlich die aktienkurse der
rüstungsindustrie in die höhe zu treiben
da machen wir als linke nicht mit
die fraktionsvorsitzende der linken
fordert ein sofortiges kriegsende wer
glaube putin sei militärisch zu
bezwingen der ampera mohammed ali
fordert friedensverhandlungen man müsse
mit putin verhandeln dabei sei vor allem
die außenministerin gefordert gibt sei
diplomatie gebracht nächster redner
achim post von der spd
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren wir
reden ja heute über den europäischen rat
in einer ganz besonderen situation
in einer situation die ich jedenfalls
noch nicht erlebt haben
und wir reden in deutschland und europa
über
einen brutalen angriffskrieg putins auf
die ukraine mit schon jetzt tausenden
und abertausenden von opfern
in den letzten
hunderten von jahren in hunderten von
jahren war europa stets ein kontinent
des krieges durch die europäische union
durch die europäische einigung durch den
europäischen zusammenhalt
ist europa nach dem zweiten weltkrieg zu
einem kontinent des friedens geworden
und das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sollten uns immer vor augen halten wenn
wir hier über das eine oder andere
innenpolitische scharmützel reden das
ist aus meiner sicht nämlich auch nicht
angemessen bei dem was hier diskutiert
wird
und nach dem wieso friedensordnung vor
30 jahren durch die balkankriege im
ehemaligen jugoslawien zerstört wurde
wird sie jetzt gerade zerstört durch
putin und seinem brutalen angriffs
kriegen ich halte es für die richtige
die angemessene reaktion wenn der
bundeskanzler sagt er fährt auf diesen
gipfel mit klaren zielen mit dem ziel
europa zu stärken mit dem ziel europas
sicherheitspolitik zu stärken mit dem
ziel europas demokratie zu stärken und
wird diesen kurs liebe kollege und
kollegen hat der bundeskanzler und hat
die gesamte bundesregierung die
unterstützung der gesamten spd
bundestagsfraktion
und worauf kommt es an worauf kommt es
jetzt an in der europäischen union es
kommt an auf handlungsfähigkeit und
zusammenhalt und ich finde die häufig zu
unrecht viel gescholtene europäische
union hat in den letzten wochen hat in
den letzten zehn zwölf wochen die
handlungsfähigkeit an den tag gelegt mit
wirtschaftshilfen mit humanitärer hilfe
mit der aufnahme von flüchtlingen mit
waffenlieferungen mit unzähligen
initiativen führt diplomatie in richtung
waffenstillstand und auch mit einem
sanktionspaket mit mehreren
sanktionspaket die ihresgleichen suchen
und die wirken und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist es richtig
dass wir auf dem europäischen rat über
dinge reden über die wir früher nie
geredet hätten aber das machen wir das
wird der bundeskanzler machen und die
bundesregierung ich finde es richtig
dass auf der tagesordnung des nächsten
rates steht ein öl-embargo gegen
russland so schwer einem das auffällt es
gibt dazu wenig alternativen liebe
kollegin kolleg ich finde es auch
richtig dass nicht auf der tagesordnung
steht ein gas embargo denn bei allen
sanktionen und das hat der bundeskanzler
betont geht es darum dass es vor allen
dingen putin schadet vor allen dingen
russland schadet und nicht uns selbst
und deshalb ist das aus der
bundeskanzlerin vorgetragen hat genau
der richtige kurs die tolle
unterstützung das gesagt das verdient
und ich finde es richtig
und klug
dass auf dem gipfel darüber geredet wird
wie die europäische sicherheit und
verteidigungsfähigkeit gestärkt wird
hier wurde angesprochen schweden und
finnland schweden war 200 jahre lang
neutrale finnland gehörte länger zum
russischen zarenreich als es
eigenständig ist diese beiden länder
unter der führung zweier
regierungschefin und ministerpräsidentin
habe in zehn wochen gezeigt was eine
zeitenwende bedeutet sie haben nämlich
all das was sie hundert oder zweihundert
jahre für richtig gehalten habe über
bord geworfen weil es eine völlig neue
bedrohungen in europa gibt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und der bundeskanzler darauf hingewiesen
auf diesem rat muss und wird auch
darüber geredet wie es eigentlich mit
der beitrittsperspektive für den
westlichen balkan aussieht und was aus
den versprechen geworden ist wie die
europäische union und die viele
regierungen in europa seit vielen jahren
den mitgliedern des westlichen balkans
machen ich bin dafür dass man die
versprechungen in realitäten umsetzt und
schritt für schritt die länder des
westlichen balkans in die europäische
integration in die europäische union
integriert sauber ist es allerhöchste
zeit
und wenn wir über die ukraine reden
wenn wir europa europa und die ukraine
reden das ist doch klar und ich sehe
hier gar nicht so viele unterschiede
dass wir tatkräftig den weg der ukraine
in die europäische union unterstützen
werden liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn man darüber redet weichen
richtig zu stellen wenn man darüber
redet weichen richtig zu stellen und das
muss man heute machen damit europa auf
morgen weiter stark ist dann ist es gut
dass wir eine zukunftskonferenz
europäische union hatten und haben mit
vielen guten vorschlägen mit vielen
guten vorschlägen die wir uns alle
anschauen werden und zwar so schnell wie
möglich denn ich glaube das ist nötig
ist das ist notwendig ist das ist
geboten ist das ist zeitgemäß ist in der
europäischen union einige dinge zu
verbessern auch für mehr integration zu
sorgen wenn das innerhalb der verträge
geht wunderbar dann machen wir das
innerhalb der verträge wenn es nötig ist
es außerhalb der verträge zu machen dann
machen wir das außerhalb der verträge
und organisieren über einen konvent neue
möglichkeiten wird das weitere
zusammenwachsen der europäischen union
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zusammen gefasst es steht viel auf dem
spiel
und jeder oppositionsführer jede
oppositionsführerin kann hier zum glück
sagen was er oder was sie will denn das
ist ein freies land ein freies parlament
aber jeder muss auch wissen was er hier
sagt in einer solchen situation wo mehr
auf dem spiel steht als die nächste
kommunalwahl irgendwo in deutschland
steht auf dem spiel frieden und
sicherheit ihrer obacht schönen danken
das war achim post von der spd m not
nicht wirklich erstaunlich den kanzler
aber auch die eu das öl-embargo gegen
russland sei wichtig dass aber ein
gangbarer und nicht auf der tagesordnung
stehe seit ebenfalls richtig es folgten
alexander dobrindt vorsitzender der
csu-landesgruppe
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
der europäischen rates mit großen
erwartungen verbunden dass dort themen
auf der agenda stehen die die
europäische zukunft auf jahre hinaus
prägen werden ja und es wird darum gehen
wie man mit den folgen des krieges in
der ukraine umgehen muss mit
finanzieller unterstützung mit
notwendigen waffen liefern mit
humanitärer unterstützung ja dass es
alles zwingend notwendig aber es wird
auch darüber gehen wie wir ein neues
sicherheits gleichgewicht in europa
schaffen können wie wir zukünftige
kriege vermeiden lieber die einheit
europas sichert wie wir stabilität neue
schaffen können und da haben wir zu
wenig gehört heute der bundeskanzler
sie haben den französischen präsidenten
makro zitiert der angekündigt hat dass
er auch diesem rat über institutionelle
reformen der eu sprechen will herr
bundeskanzler sie haben gesagt ja das
sei kein tabu darüber zu sprechen aber
sie haben uns nicht gesagt wie ihre
vorschläge sind makros sagt
wirtschaftwachstum klima soziale fragen
und die erweiterung der eu sind sein
thema von ihnen kennen wir nur das
bekenntnis zu einer europäischen
schulden union und einer europäischen
arbeitslosenversicherung beides ist
schlichtweg falsch wir brauchen keine
schulden union wir brauchen keine
europäische arbeitslosenversicherung das
was wir brauchen ist eine neue kultur
der stabilität
eine ambitionierte europäische
verteidigung zur und darüber hätten wir
wohl nie etwas gehört
wir brauchen auf diesem europäischen rat
die debatte über neue
sicherheitsgarantien
sicherheitsgarantien bei der frage der
militärischen zusammenarbeit und rüstung
inflationsbekämpfung und
wohlstandssicherung und
sicherheitsgarantien bei der
weiterentwicklung einer europäischen
union ohne dass sie überdehnt wird und
dass eine teilhabe an dem
friedensprojekt eu möglich ist außerhalb
einer vollmitgliedschaft darüber hätten
wir gerne etwas gehört beispielsweise
bei der sicherheit der militärischen
zusammenarbeit ja es ist richtig ein
baustein für die rüstung und für die
sicherheit sind ihre ankündigungen aus
ihrer rede der zeitenwende vom 27
februar sie haben da gesprochen vom
sondervermögen bundeswehr von
rüstungsvorhaben und von der dauerhaften
einhaltung des zwei prozent ziels herr
bundeskanzler
heute haben sie
das zwei prozent ziel in ihrer rede
nicht mehr erwähnt ich hoffe das war nur
ein versehen sie haben hier an dieser
stelle ein doppel versprechen abgegeben
100 milliarden euro und die zwei prozent
ich hoffe dass das kein hinweis heute
war dass ihre historische rede vom 27
februar bereits geschichte ist meine
damen und herren
ja es ist richtig wir befinden uns
aktuell auch in gesprächen
ich darf ihnen aber an der stelle herr
bundeskanzler auch sagen dass es noch
kein stück papier gibt auf dem steht das
100 milliarden euro für die streitkräfte
ins grundgesetz geschrieben werden und
zwei prozent jedes jahr zur erfüllung
der nato quote vereinbart sind das liegt
schlichtweg nicht an uns und liebe
kollegin dröge wenn es um die
bündnisfähigkeit geht dann lassen sie
sich bitte sagen nichts stärkt mehr
unsere bündnisfähigkeit als 100
milliarden in die streitkräfte zu
stecken das ist die aufgabe die dahinter
stehen
und ich will an dieser stelle auch damit
sie nicht als fraktionsvorsitzender der
spd haben sie diese woche sich
öffentlich geäußert und in bezug auf 100
milliarden und 2 prozent ziel davon
gesprochen dass die union von ihren
maximalforderungen abstand nehmen sollte
wir stellen keine maximalforderungen
aber wir erwarten dass das was der
bundeskanzler der öffentlichkeit
versprochen hat von den ampel
koalitionären mindestens eingehalten
wird das erwarten wir an dieser stelle
es geht um sicherheitsgarantien für die
inflationsbekämpfung und die
bestandssicherung die inflation
entwickelt sich zur massiven gefahr für
wachstum und wohlstand in europa in
deutschland mit über 7 prozent in
unseren nachbarländern in europa
mittlerweile bei deutlich über zehn
prozent bei den damen und herren die
inflation in europa ist die stille
enteignung der sparer die stille
entwertung der kleinen und mittleren
einkommen der bundeskanzler die usa hat
den kampf gegen die inflation zum
topthema der amerikanischen innenpolitik
gemacht sie reden gerne vom sozialen
europa ich sage ihnen die steigende
inflation schafft ein unsoziales in
europa deswegen machen die insel camp
punkt zum top thema ritter
von wir brauchen auch eine
sicherheitsgarantie bezüglich der frage
der fortentwicklung der europäischen
union ja die sicherheitspolitische lage
die sich verändert hat führt dazu dass
zunehmend auch neue länder schnell in
die europäische union beitreten wollen
die sechs balkanstaaten haben sie
genannt sie haben unsere unterstützung
ukraine moldau georgien stehen an der
schwelle wir müssen auch darauf achten
dass wir die europäische union nicht
überfordern ja es braucht eine
perspektive für diese länder ukraine
moldau georgien ja aber wir wissen dass
beitrittsverhandlungen jahre und
teilweise jahrzehnte dauern es ist jetzt
ihre aufgabe eine neue
respektive auch für diese länder zu
schaffen ich sage ihnen es braucht jetzt
bei diesem rat eine verhandlung darüber
wie wir eine beitrittsperspektive zum
friedensprojekt europäische union
schaffen können ohne dabei mit einer
vollmitgliedschaft die europäische union
zu überdehnen da haben sie eine aufgabe
und da erwarten wir nun in einer antwort
herzlichen dank
so wir blenden uns an dieser stelle aus
einer recht lebhaften debatte und
schalten noch einmal zu meiner kollegin
andrea maurer andrea haben wir da gerade
einen typischen olaf scholz erlebt oder
hat er es geschafft endlich mal
verständlich vielsagend und klar zu
kommunizieren
nun ich würde sagen es war ein scheiß
der sich in teilen ein bisschen
sozusagen ergänzt hat also er hat ein
paar dinger noch mal justiert und
versucht ein bisschen deutlicher zu sein
beispielsweise hat er sich an die seite
von dem französischen präsidenten makro
nun gestellt und gesagt es wird nicht
schnell gehen für die ukraine was ein
beitrittsprozess oder einen beitritt
betrifft da ist ja also ein bisschen
konkreter geworden als in den letzten
tagen und er ist in einer sache noch mal
sagen wir mal ein bisschen deutlicher
geworden er hat seinem satz russland
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen um den
zusatz ergänzt hat die ukraine muss
bestehen also das ist sozusagen die
deutlichkeit die man von olaf scholz
hier kriegen kann mehr mehr ist da nicht
wobei es natürlich in der eu auch andere
positionen gibt es gibt zum beispiel die
position von estland die sagt ukrainer
muss militärisch siegen das ist also in
der eu durchaus umstritten was einen
frieden oder ein ende des krieges in der
ukraine bedeutet und da hat olaf scholz
heute eben diesen satz gesagt russland
darf den krieg nicht gewinnen die
ukraine muss bestehen das ist das was
heute bleibt also ergänzt sich da in
bestimmten positionen und wird ein
bisschen deutlicher ist ein bisschen
deutlicher geworden aber sozusagen eine
große wucht hat diese rede
nach meiner auffassung nicht entfaltet
schauen wir mal auf die rede von
friedrich merz hat diese rede denn große
bucht also er hat ja viel kritisiert hat
die regierung heftig kritisiert und auch
beim thema sondervermögen scheint eine
einigung noch nicht in sicht zu sein wie
war denn seine rede
nun es war die rede eines
oppositionsführers eine klare angriffs
rede er hat natürlich die offenen
pflanzen die der kanzler gelassen hat
sozusagen genutzt er hat seinen finger
in offene wunden gelegt er hat ja seine
rede begonnen mit einem zitat des
kanzlers er würde nicht in die ukraine
reisen weil er nicht derjenige sei der
nur für einen fototermin dahin ging und
friedrich merz hat dann eine lange liste
von verbündeten und kabinettsmitgliedern
aufgezählt die in die ukraine gefahren
sind und damit eigentlich auch den auf
frauen deutlich gemacht den der kanzler
mit diesen worten im grunde genommen
vollzogen hat das war sozusagen die
startrampe auf der friedrich merz denn
da weiter gemacht hat er hat im grunde
genommen den kanzler mit den worten
zitiert dass sozusagen waffenlieferungen
an die ukraine der ukraine helfen sich
zu verteidigen und keine eskalation sein
da hat olaf scholz ja vor wochen noch
anders geklungen darauf hat friedrich
merz aufmerksam gemacht er hat die im
grunde ein doppeltes spiel bei den
waffenlieferungen also eine
verzögerungstaktik
unterstellt und am ende hat er eben auch
den kanzler dazu aufgefordert sich von
der verteidigungsministerin zu trennen
also sie zu entlassen das war eine sehr
deutliche rede eine sehr deutliche
anklage rede und hat den kanzler da eben
auch an einigen punkten gepackt wo man
ihm durchaus vorwürfe machen kann
ja du hast es eben erwähnt die
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht ist ja
sehr in der kritik hierzu gab es heute
eigentlich kein wort von olaf scholz wie
ist dein eindruck wie sicher ist sie
noch im job trotz aller kritik friedrich
merz hat ja ganz klar ihren rücktritt
gefordert und wie wird das einschätzen
wie ist die situation jetzt auch nach
den landtagswahlen wo ja zum beispiel
die fdp massiv verloren hat in der ampel
steht die ampel trotzdem noch zusammen
wie der eindruck
also zum ersten punkt lambrecht da würde
ich sagen das ist typisch für olaf
scholz das wenn er dazu aufgefordert
irgendetwas zu tun er es nicht tut also
er ist auch dafür bekannt dass er im
grunde genommen an ministern und
ministerin festhält das war schon in
hamburg so das heißt es eben auch in der
spd beispielsweise dass er das auch hier
in seinem aktuellen kabinett tun wird
das heißt dass friedrich martin dazu
auffordert frau lamprecht zu entlassen
wird jetzt nicht die konsequenz haben
dass olaf scholz das tut und zum anderen
die nrw-wahl hat natürlich gezeigt dass
im grunde genommen die beiden parteien
die
bundespolitisch am deutlichsten für eine
unterstützung der ukraine sind also die
cdu und die grünen das sind die parteien
die in nrw
sozusagen bei den wählern und
wählerinnen gewonnen haben und das
dürfte auch ein signal oder dürfte auch
von der spd durchaus verstanden worden
sein ja vielen dank andrea ich bedanke
mich für ihr interesse hier geht es
jetzt weiter mit der sendung notruf
hafenkante
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen tag
und sage tschüss bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
maybrit illner